tant que cette boîte c'est une histoire
de coeur en fête c'est absolument c'est
j'ai rencontré j'ai rencontré laetitia
il y a neuf ans à miami
ouais et j'aime assez drôle d'ailleurs
presque à l'époque jean roch travailler
pour andré boudou le père de laeticia
le père du disparu et une téléphone et à
l'hôtel il me téléphone je devais partir
loin même téléphone il me disait qu'il
super sport je dis rien je que les
familles amis du si tu veux on dîne
ensemble eu d'accord ils arrivent en
voiture avec ordre et vous où laëtitia
et la femme d'andré on va dîner après on
va on va à l'amnesia de l'ue n'y a ni de
miami et puis la soeur espace on va dans
votre boîte est bon on rentre tard et
puis le lendemain je revois laetitia et
puis je rentre sur paris et donc je
rentre sur paris on a continué à acheter
des faunes et caetera et puis un mois
après laetitia je vais éviter l'épée à
paris et je vais rester une semaine et
puis il n'est jamais reparti elle avait
un billet vert oui mais il n'a jamais
aussi avait le brc pas remboursés j'ai
voulu faire j'ai voulu faire par rapport
à par rapport à l'endroit où je l'avais
rencontrée je voulais faire la boîte de
nuit j'y suis allé hier donc c'est là
qu'on sait qu'on s'est connus on
pourrait dire même a fait un petit
reportage
la voulu reconstituer l'ambiance de
miami
l'aïe a barré c'est combien de bardot
dans trois bars avec des journées si le
remède dans huit jours à vous elle est
habillée commet le moins possible
j'espère sexy sexy il au fond qu'est-ce
qu'il va y avoir là une cascade d'eau 1
d'accord un qui entoure la tête
alors là ici ça c'est les caissons de
basses en main avec un mais au dessus on
va avoir des finances
trois filles si perfectible comme par
hasard par les dj ça sera toi lui dit sa
vérité
alors que j'étais dj mois 1 à saison
risque moi j'en ai pas tu vois batta
concurrents
il ya comme un de gens il faut venir ici
à peu près 1500 1800 ha oui c'est quoi
la boîte que tu as préféré que tout est
là si tu devais pas par celle là puisque
c'est toi qui l'a quand j'étais plus
jeune j'ai tout le temps c'est l elysée
matignon ça n'existe plus et surtout il
est alors le ballon mais où quoi qu'on
devient souvent l'essentiel c'est utile
mais pour moi c'est une occasion de
ressortir le plus c'est vrai que
dernièrement je sortais plus parce que
je m'ennuyais dans les boîtes ne trouvez
pas vraiment les la boîte où je veux où
je veux m'amuser comme avoir vu on a
quatre leurs titres courts plus la
sortie pour les
les handicapés donc ça va on peut
allumer le feu ça
geiger
c'est parfait ça fait traiter à moi je
rentrais si je dois je le fais en
s'amusant je te connais je pourrais
gauche pour je peux venir à tostat
vivent des soirées spéciales il va y
avoir des soirées spéciales
non maintenant parce que lui quand il
est spécial c'est vrai bon écoute on va
se voir peut-être plus souvent qu depuis
20 ans quant à une boîte
ouais bien sûr mais tu sais moi je parle
je ne veux pas faire de concurrence aux
autres tenues matière j'ai plein d'amis
dans la de nuit qui on doit le bois toi
jean roch c'est pas la même chose
le queen c'est pas le même principe on
est tous amis on se croit que plus tôt
on se complète plutôt main plutôt que de
se faire la tire beaucoup d'e mails pour
dire qu'est ce que c'est que cette boîte
le quoi le cui
le queens